[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs de 2018 ça va vous
surprendre mais je viens du futur
j'arrive tout droit de l'année 2000 78
alors je vois les sceptiques des gens
qui se disent ils viennent futur
pourquoi il a si peu de cheveux sur la
tête
ne vous méprenez pas dans le futur nous
avons clairement gagné le combat contre
la calvitie
mais si j'ai choisi d'apparaître devant
vous comme monsieur comme monsieur avec
un cheveu sur deux sur la tête c'est
pour vous paraître plus familier quand
mes jean pierre o et jean-luc de votre
époque je vois encore des sceptiques des
gens qui pensent que je blague que
j'aime vente que je m'étonne que je
fabule que je rigole oui dans le futur
nous aimons utilisé de nombreux synonyme
pour exprimer une pensée simple les
droits d'auteur est un décompte et à la
seconde
je vais gagner un petit peu d'argent
avec ça et c'est normal que vous soyez
sceptiques
c'est la première fois que vous êtes
confrontés une altération du temps de
l'espace et pour vous prouver que je
viens du futur que j'ai des
connaissances que seul un habitant de
2068 peut avoir sur votre époque je vais
maintenant réaliser 3 prédictions qui
vont vérifier pendant l'intervention
ma première prédiction et que le
téléphone du cameraman va sonner
il sera gêné mais pas tant que ça
c'est que membre de l'audience en mots
femme va avoir une crise cardiaque
pendant mon intervention et qui n'aura
pas la décence d'attendre la fin de
celle ci pour décédé un peu par
obligation beaucoup par manque de
politesse ma troisième prédiction c'est
qu'un écureuil géant va venir sur scène
danser sur la musique de carmina burana
et vous épatera par son charisme
première prédiction est pas tant gêné
sens
[Musique]
stop
un autre époque les écureuils fond
qu'est cm ce n'est qu'à partir de 1060
qui vont multi et devenir des géants de
mettre 60 et pouvoir danser lors de la
grande rébellion des rongeurs ce que
l'on va faire c'est pour remettre la
bonne ambiance on va ressusciter
monsieur voilà on a cette technologie
dans le futur c'est assez simple non si
tu dis le secret ça marche pas vous le
découvrirez bien plus tard je vais très
animé mais tu dois rien dire d'accord là
tu dois rien dire alors pourquoi suis-je
ici pour réparer une erreur commise par
les organisateurs du tedx canebière dans
le futur d'où je viens cette conférence
a déjà eu lieu le dernier intervenant
est un ventriloque bulgare accompagné
d'une poupée constitué de chaussettes
recycler son intervention a été une
catastrophe
il a gâché le tedx car en plus d'être
médiocre un ventriloque et il s'est
révélé légèrement misogyne et totalement
nationaliste sur twitter des ordres de
haters ce qu'est un pléonasme
sur twitter les internautes se sont
emparés du phénomène et ont contraint
les organisateurs du tennis canebière à
mettre la clé usb sous la porte
certains sont devenus alcoolique
d'autres sont tombés dans la dépression
d'autant cumuler les deux un croyant la
mairie de marseille
mais tous ont regretté toute leur vie
d'avoir programmé ce ventre il opte
bulgare dans le nom laissait présager
des astres hilario le ventriloque
bornier rigolo accompagné de poupette sa
poupée nationalistes pour ça maintenant
je suis là pour l'an passé et je vois
qu'un accueil en juin 2000 78
les petits enfants des organisateurs du
jeu existe canebière entendu leurs
grands parents pendant des années ce
plein de cet événement en particulier et
en 2060 jusqu'à le premier protocole de
voyage dans le temps a été instauré ils
ont organisé kickstarter pour me
renvoyer dans le passé et corriger les
erreurs dans leurs grands parents
je vois qui en a qui ont du mal avec le
voyage temporel
je pensais que vu le prix du ticket vous
étiez csp + mais je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup david ce soir il ya vous ne
passerez pas le stade et ceux de la
seconde équation c'est pas grave s cana
qui se demandent encore où sont passés
hilario le ventriloque bordier rigolo et
poupette quitter immédiatement la salle
vous n'avez pas du tout le niveau du
tedx alors quand les organisateurs m'ont
dit le sujet de la conférence et retour
vers le futur
ils ont cru bon de préciser surtout tu
ne parles pas du film et le film quel
film le film de science fiction
américain réalisé par robert zemeckis
sorti en 1985 le film dans les intrigues
relate le voyage dans le passé de
l'adolescent marty mcfly aidé par le doc
emmett bronn à l'aide d'une machine à
voyager dans le temps constitué d'une
voiture de douleur et en deux modèles
mc12 plongé de 85 à 1955 marty mcfly
doigts et et du dock de 1955 résoudre
les paradoxes temporels et induit par sa
présence dans le passé et réparer la
machine pour retourner à son époque
d'origine c'est ce final que vous parlez
au curry je n'ai même pas vu par contre
je viens de gagner l'équivalent de la
grèce en droit d'auteur oui d'un futur
comme dans le passé le présent c'est
mieux être riche beaucoup mieux si vous
êtes riche ça veut dire qu en 2039
vous allez vous pouvoir quitter la terre
ce qui sera une bonne idée il fera 53
degrés en hiver et des spas sitôt sera
toujours numéro 1 au top 50
à mon époque l'eau a tellement monté que
l'afrique est la taille de la corse que
la corse et l'atlantide et que mars n
existe plus ce sont trois bonnes raisons
à continuer à polluer me direz vous mais
abstenez vous si vous êtes pauvres ou
allergiques alliotte à mon épaule dans
le futur la ressource la plus précieuse
celle eau potable
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'à votre
époque la ressource la plus précieuse
c'est aussi l'eau potable mais comme il
suffit d'ouvrir le robinet pour un avoir
vous n'y faites plus du tout attention
est ce que vous savez qui détient les
plus grandes réserves d'eau en 2018
c'est le canada en 2036 la présidente
céline dion va fermer les frontières du
canada
elle va déclarer le québec nations
souveraines aquatique indépendante
épousé un dauphin béluga dauphin relooké
avec lots à six enfants six enfants
partiront cruel dans l'activité
principale sera de renverser des barques
de migrants climatiques rendant vrai
l'expression migrations climatiques
beaucoup d'appelés peu d'élus l'eau le
cycle de l'eau c'est très simple il ya
de l'eau elle s'évapore
il pleut et à de l'eau à l'heure
actuelle il ya de l'eau ont la peau lui
elle s'évapore
il peut de l'acide l'acide s'évapore
godzilla arrive vous utilisé
principalement l'eau actuellement pour
lui l'agriculture non a résolu ce
problème il ya plus d'agriculture il ya
plus de fruits bon mauvais il ya plus de
légumes
la terre est stérile et vous le problème
de notre agriculture c'est de ce n'est
pas le produire en quantité insuffisante
mais de produire en quantité
disproportionnée qui a besoin de manger
des tomates en hiver ou des blettes en
été personne personne n'a jamais besoin
de manger bled c'est dégueulasse
l'ablette et un repas ce que karim
benzema est à l'équipe de france en
poupe en vouloir mais non on va s'en
passer en fait actuellement des
supermarchés on trouve des mandarines et
peluches et vendus dans des emballages
plastiques
vous savez qui fit qui ce qu'a fait le
travail de mieux emballé la mandarine
que vous la mandarine elle même a été
déjà emballée c'est comme si demain en
vendée des bananes épluché dans des sacs
banane ça n'a pas de sens
c'est havas les petits bleus vous suivez
toujours j'ai oublié de vous dire dans
le futur en et cache tout ce qui nous
viennent à l'esprit on le dit on n'a
plus de limites
la cour holler à ce phénomène c'est
qu'on est tous complètement débile on
est tous très content dans le futur
c'est bien simple le futur du monde et
le présent de marseille
tout a commencé par la perte du langage
écrit la paire des dictionnaires la main
sur des sms
à mon époque tout à transmission se fait
à l'oral et croyez - germinal où les
misérables chanté par patrick sébastien
ça n'a pas la même profondeur sociale
arrêtez de tout demander à google google
n'est pas votre ami google est l'ami des
actionnaires de google google inventé à
votre époque une intelligence
artificielle qui s'appelle alpha go le
but de cette intelligence artificielle
et d'apprendre à jouer au jeu de go un
jeu millénaire cali mathématiques
stratégie intuition je doute on penser
que jamais une machine ne pourrait
rivaliser avec la subtilité de l'esprit
humain en a pris alpha go on ya fait
affronter le champion du monde 2 go la
machine à écraser lui mais elle a
humilié mais le pire est à venir puisque
une semaine après la machine à coachella
réfléchir à devenir plus en plus
intelligente elle a compris qu'elle
avait passé toute sa vie de machine à
apprendre le jeu aussi pourri que
legault alors il s'est suicidé en
ouvrant une pièce jointe
les gens aient l'intelligence
artificielle aujourd'hui elle est
partout on vous l'a dit est temps au
téléphone elle est dans vos maisons les
dans vos voitures
le seul endroit où l'intelligence
artificielle n'est pas ça l'école c'est
à dire le seul endroit où on distribue
d'intelligence ya pas d'intelligence
artificielle
par contre y'a des distributeurs de
préservatifs et de coca cola car c'est
vrai qu'un brevet bien réussi ce fait d
une orgie dans le cauca c'est connu il
n'ya jamais un chercheur aux
développeurs qui se dit que peut-être
une intelligence artificielle pourrait
corriger les copies à la passe de
professeurs et le décharger de ce stage
peu de rébarbatif
que peut-être l'intelligence
artificielle pour évaluer les élèves
chaque soir et les aider sur les points
qui n'ont pas compris non l'intelligence
artificielle est allé à l'école ce que
la morale et à la politique est la
meilleure solution qui ne sera jamais
appliquée mais rassurez vous dans le
futur l'école n'est plus obligatoire
il suffit d'écrire les diplômes que vous
voulez sur linkedin et personne ne
vérifie votre cv
c'est comme aujourd'hui c'est pour ça
qu'à actuellement moi je suis titulaire
d'un master en archéologie un
spécialisée dans la confection des pâtes
à carbonara un stick ingénieurs en un
clé usb
mesdames et messieurs de 2018 je vais
pas pouvoir rester beaucoup plus
longtemps avec vous tout simplement le
voyage dans le temps est rendu possible
grâce à cette machine c'est un
transpondeur temporel à ionisation
féminisé alors comment ça marche
on prend un chat ce chat en en
l'introduit d'un story fils il est moyen
ce qui libère son énergie féline et
permet le voyage dans le temps il faut à
peu près un chat par minutes
d'intervention
voilà on arrive au bout d'une porte et
c'est pour ça que je vais m'en retourne
à mon époque mes amis de 2018
spectateurs du tedx canebière là ce
moment où il faut que vous soyez honnête
avec moi s cana qui croient encore que
je viens pas du futur
à cela je n'ai qu'une réponse apportée
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup